on August 5th 1857 a 4,300 kilometer
long cable was laid across the Atlantic
Ocean it provided a link between Britain
and the Americas further strengthening
their social and economic alliances it
was hoped to bring perpetual peace and
friendship between kindred nations now
information could be represented as a
pattern of electrical pulses and sent
across the world almost instantaneously
stock tickers and money transfers were
commercial applications invented by
Western Union who owned an extensive buy
for this announcement Germany has
invaded Poland and has bombed many towns
general mobilization has been ordered
input
consequently this country is at war with
Germany the world which is the real
cause of the war that today threatens
the freedom of mankind
it's a favicon sunyata i
the Japanese have attacked Pearl Harbor
Hawaii by air President Roosevelt has
just announced
a World War two Germany Italy in Japan
were far outnumbered by the Allies their
only conceivable path to victory was the
ability to launch widespread surprise
attacks so it was necessary to issue
commands encrypted with the strongest
possible cipher the goal of encryption
was to automate the one-time pad using
an encryption machine ideally this
machine would accept an input letter
apply random shift and output the
encrypted letters however this requires
a machine that can automate a random
sequence all machines follow the same
principle they begin in some initial
configuration known as a state they
accept input do some operation with the
input and display the outline the
operation from the initial state to
final state is always predictable and
repeatable machines cannot roll dice
what machines can do however is produce
a pseudo-random sequence of numbers
think of this as fake randomness a
repeatable sequence of random looking
numbers it will look random if at every
point in the sequence you are unable to
predict the next number it's vital that
this sequence never repeats but
mechanical procedures are repetitive by
nature so the goal was to produce the
sequence which took a long time to
repeat therefore Alice and Bob could
generate an identical pseudo-random
sequence as follows first they share
identical machines next agree on a
random initial position which is defined
as the key setting they align their
machines to the same position and
finally cycle through the identical
operations to achieve identical
sequences however this requires the
initial condition to be a truly random
choice we are familiar with the
mechanical process of an Adama tur which
takes a long time to repeat its cycle
imagine we scramble the numbers on the
wheels of an abdominal or word a new
shift is generated by adding up the
numbers on each rotor this is the idea
behind rotor encryption machines for
example the message attack Northwest
would be encrypted as follows notice how
a new shift is used at each position in
the message with 3 wheels each with 26
numbers the length of the sequence
before repeating is 26 times 26 times 26
this is equivalent to having a
pseudo-random list of shifts 17,576
numbers long
each rotor position is equivalent to a
location in the sequence the initial
machine state is known as a key setting
the collection of all possible key
settings defines a key space this key
space increases if the number of ways to
initially configure the machine
increases for example if the rotors can
be rearranged the order can be selected
in six ways now let's visualize the key
space of this machine first we can
choose from one of six possible
orderings then we can select an initial
position from the rotor sequence this
gives us a key space with over a hundred
thousand key settings realize that every
machine configuration is a point in this
space when we select a key setting we
are selecting a starting point in this
space which determines the rest of the
sequence give away the key setting and
you give away the sequence the security
of rotor machines depends on both the
size of the key space and the randomness
of the key setting during World War two
one of the important technologies used
by the German military was known as the
Enigma it was an electromechanical rotor
machine invented by a German engineer at
the end of World War one each rotor
wheel had electrical contacts on either
side with a maze of wirings within at
each rotor position there was an
electrical path from the input letter to
the output letter when the rotor
advanced an entirely new path was
defined for each letter during the war
they continually increase the key space
of the Enigma in order to make it
stronger this gave the more confidence
in the security of their machine some
changes they made were to add a fourth
rotor wheel and increase the number of
possible rotors you could put into the
machine 260 this had the effect of
massively increasing the key space near
the end of the war the Enigma could be
set up in over a hundred 50 mil
million ways guessing what key setting
was used for a given message would be
approximately as likely as guessing the
outcome of 26 dice rolls this gave the
Germans confidence that the Allies even
if they had a copy of the Enigma could
never check all possible key settings
for two parties to communicate using me
and make mine it required that they
first share the daily key settings this
allows them to align their machines in
the same position this protocol changed
over the war but generally involve
distributing key sheets in advance to
all operators each day the operator
would cut off the daily settings this
would tell them the daily configuration
of the machine such as what rotors to
use in the order of the rotors then the
setting was to be destroyed after use
however when vital step was left to the
operator they were to select a random
initial position of each rotor before
communication began and a simple mistake
was made by some fatigued operators we
make the same mistake when we set a bike
lock combination because we tend to
rotate the cylinders only a few clicks
from the initial state or we reuse a
common password this altered the uniform
distribution of each initial rotor
position repetition is fatal the second
major error was a design error not a
procedural one the Enigma was designed
so that an input letter would never
encrypt to itself so given an encrypted
letter such as L you can eliminate the
possibility of L being the original
letter which also alters the frequency
distribution away from uniform these
mistakes add up to larger and larger
differentials in the frequency
distribution this differential is the
cause of information leak because it
allows you to eliminate possible
settings the shrinking the key space
this weakness led to a code breaking
machine initially designed by the poles
and later improved by the British
American effort the bombe was multiple
enigma rotors chained together allowing
it to rapidly test different key
settings for a given message it could
scan through all rotor positions and
orders to find possible matches in a
matter of minutes
this machine allowed the Allies to read
German commands within hours of them
being issued it was a fatal blow to
their strategy as the Allies could
anticipate their next moves one fact
remains this initial attempt at
generating pseudo randomness failed if
the operators had instead rolled dice to
decide their initial rotor positions the
starting pointless sequence would have
been uniformly distributed this would
have required the Allies to check the
entire key space which was impossible
even with the fastest computer
repetition reduce the key space
otherwise the outcome of World War two
could have been drastically different